thank you very much president Mr
President we'll talk about Ukraine and
the Western Balkans in just a moment but
first looking at the current events in
China I would like to ask for your
assessment what type of reaction do you
expect from Beijing
I feel it's very difficult to say just
what is happening because we currently
have so little information but of course
I'm following it closely and the images
that we're seeing from Beijing and other
cities around China move me
we all remember our own fight against
the coronavirus against the pandemic and
still remember how heavily it weighed on
so many in Germany
we can only wonder what a burden it must
be for the people of China where
measures are far stricter and further
reaching even today
so I understand why people want to voice
their impatience and their grievances on
the streets
as a Democrat I can only say that the
freedom to express one's own opinion is
important and I can only hope that
authorities in China respect the right
to freedom of expression and the freedom
to demonstrate
and of course I hope the demonstrations
remain peaceful
what we are witnessing in Ukraine really
has nothing to do with actual war in
terms of military operations it is a war
against civilians why is Putin doing
this and what does it change for Germany
I would dispute the idea that it has
nothing to do with the War I believe
what we are seeing is part of the
Russian war strategy
not only do we have a brutal war of
invasion being waged against the
Ukrainian Army but also and this is
becoming clearer as winter approaches a
brutal attack on critical infrastructure
and with that of course on the civilian
population
we fear and this is something we have
seen in recent weeks with the
destruction of gas heating and
electricity infrastructure what might
await the people of Ukraine hardship
darkness and
colder on and these are not coincidental
side effects but rather it looks as if
they are in fact the aim of Russian
attacks and that part of Russia's
strategy is to hit the civilian
population to grind down the entire
country
and that is what our solidarity has to
stand up to and that is why we have to
help to guarantee these people survive
the coming winter
Germany is helping Ukraine even with
arms deliveries Ukraine has meanwhile
begun praising Berlin for supplying
weapons yet Kiev is still waiting for
battle tanks isn't this war against the
civilian population reason enough for
Berlin to reconsider its approach
I feel that there has not only been a
lot of thought in Germany but also a
complete rethink we understood we had to
make decisions and that doesn't apply to
the administration alone but to the
entire German population who in just a
few short weeks in just a few months
recognize that the security we had come
to know in Europe was no longer
guaranteed
that led to the government passing
massive defense spending measures as
well as better equipping the bundesphere
above all it actually led to us
providing not only humanitarian
financial and economic assistance to
Ukraine But ultimately far more military
assistance
I've been to Ukraine as you know and I
can say the criticism that was being
leveled against Germany over arms
support has subsided and there is
instead a great deal of appreciation
today
I also believe that the German federal
government went with the right kind of
support when I was there air raid sirens
wailed daily and people had to wait out
attacks in bomb shelters
investing in air defense in protection
Against drones and especially missiles
was exactly the right thing to do
foreign
and that is now helping cities and
communities across Ukraine protect
themselves as best they can of course
there is no Total Protection but 60 to
70 percent of Russia's missiles are now
being effectively counted by the
Ukrainian Army also thanks to German
military assistance
nevertheless outside Germany many people
have the impression that Germany's first
instinct is to say no before eventually
saying yes why is that
um
attempts are made to create that
impression judging by conversations I
have and I get around in Europe and
abroad I don't get the impression that
Germany's military contributions in
solidarity with Ukraine are
underappreciated
in the kind of Ukraine recently
commemorated the 1 million victims of
the holodomor the Great Famine that took
place 90 years ago this week Germany
intends to recognize this crime as
genocide
Ukrainian president zelenski has
compared that historical crime to what
is happening today is Putin carrying out
genocide in Ukraine
this is the only do more is the hand
vibration the holiday more is a crime
that few in Germany know much about but
we must remember that it was the people
of Ukraine who were the victims of that
catastrophic famine
and the catastrophic famine was not the
result of failed harvests as had been
claimed over the course of decades
foremost by Russian historians but
rather was a targeted strategy by the
Stalin regime in 1932 and 1933 to starve
parts of the population of the then
Soviet Union in order to make them
pliable
I am very very grateful that the German
bundestag will take the opportunity to
commemorate that great tragedy this week
in a non-partisan parliamentary motion
Mr President you know the warmongers in
Moscow Putin has spoken openly about his
designs for Ukraine for years the German
leadership including yourself never took
him seriously how should one deal with
the fact that he is now threatening to
use nuclear weapons is that something
different
Essence
first I would dispute the claim that it
wasn't taken seriously just look at the
years after 2014. I don't think any
other Administration in Europe was as
engaged not only in maintaining a
ceasefire but actually using that
ceasefire as a gateway to peace
then there is the Minsk agreement that
we together with France and the then
Ukrainian president Petra boroshenko
negotiated with Russia
and you remember how I took part in
Untold numbers of attempts to achieve
progress in that Normandy format with
France Ukraine and Russia
in the end we were unsuccessful
but at the same time in my view it was
right to make the effort
in regard to the Russian threats to use
nuclear weapons I find them internal
horrible especially as they come at a
time when efforts are being made to
create a future in which nuclear weapons
are Superfluous
the threat of nuclear weapons is
therefore not only unjustified it also
runs counter to all of our historical
experiences and it is unacceptable
foreign
it is a further escalation of the war by
Russia there must be no use of nuclear
weapons and I believe that with this
stance we are in unison with nearly the
entire world
deliberations at the G20 in Bali were
another expression of the clear
rejection of such threats let alone the
actual use of nuclear weapons a clear
signal hopefully one that Moscow will
understand
what paths do you see leading out of
this wall what might a solution that is
acceptable to both sides look like
I believe anyone who claims to know what
that path is is overreaching and we are
in a phase of the war that is not headed
towards a military resolution
foreign
all I can say is thank God the people in
Ukraine are brave engaged and standing
up to the threat uh stones
we're also watching as the Ukrainian
Army drives back a purportedly Superior
adversary the Russian army
but this is not the decisive juncture
from which we can see a way out at least
I don't see one I let him feel long it
is also Reckless to suggest a ceasefire
now because to establish a ceasefire at
this point in time would essentially
condone all of the Injustice that has
already taken place
ceasefire now would mean that Russia
would keep for its own the territories
it has occupied and its breach of
borders its flouting of international
law and its land grabbing would all
receive an official blessing that cannot
be the aim of a ceasefire so sadly I
cannot say that I see any way out of the
war at this time
above all Ukraine wants security
guarantee is including from Germany
before any negotiations start is that
something Kiev can count on
Ukraine has called for that
Ukraine's demands its expectations are
known
they are also of course known within the
German federal government
and there have been signals not only
from Germany that security solidarity in
the form of security guarantees may be
feasible
but we are still at a stage where we
cannot Clearly say what those security
guarantees would look like who would
provide them and what they would have to
entail
since the content of such guarantees are
tied to the war actually ending and
since there is no end in sight right now
we cannot yet formulate security
guarantees
president Mr President we recently held
our Collective breath when two rockets
hit polish territory How great is the
fear that the war raging in Ukraine will
eventually come to us
I hope very much that that can be
avoided
and My Hope has been bolstered actually
by the very sensible reaction not only
from the United States but from NATO as
a whole
foreign
there was close communication between
the American president and the Polish
president right after the rocket impact
in eastern Poland Communications and
there was also an immediate reaction
from the head of NATO from the Secretary
General
announcing that the cause of the
incident would be investigated before a
reaction would be determined
I believe that shows that
level-headedness dominates among the
NATO countries and it also shows that a
minimum level of military contact with
Moscow remains
one thing that should be emphasized is
that both sides should make use of such
contacts if they exist
I know that according to newspaper
reports no one in Moscow picked up the
phone when they were first called that
is an additional risk that must be
avoided
and what did you think of the back and
forth that ensued after Germany offered
to station patient missile systems in
Poland
I think Germany made an offer
appropriate to the current Threat Level
how the Polish government deals with
that offer is up to them I know
discussions are also taking place in
Poland and I don't want to get involved
in them
you are about to travel to North
Macedonia and Albania the war in Ukraine
has given a new impetus to Europe as
well as to the Western Balkans will this
war speed up the process of integrating
the Western Balkans into the EU
I don't know that it will be sped up but
my trip is definitely meant to Signal
the fact that we have not forgotten
about the Western Balkans
of course we have also had debates with
our Western Balkan colleagues who voiced
concern that Ukraine's desire to join to
forge closer ties to the European Union
might be being handled differently far
more quickly than Western Balkan states
are used to
I can understand some of the impatience
and but like many others I will
guarantee people there that no one has
forgotten the Western Balkans don't
um the trip to North Macedonia and
Albania also serves to send a message to
the entire region when corresponding
domestic progress is achieved the path
to Ward membership in the European Union
also becomes more manageable
you does not have a timetable for
Western Balkan membership though some
there have set the goal of 2030 for
themselves when you speak with people
there and in the parliaments will you be
able to say whether that is realistic
it's been president
I'm the president not a prophet and that
is why I can only repeat that it all
comes down to a willingness to pass
domestic reforms and also a willingness
to implement them
and we can also deal with states in the
western Balkans differently today
because of the examples of North
Macedonia and Albania which have taken
clear steps forward
that strengthens self-confidence in
those countries and makes clear to
others in the region of the western
Balkans but taking the step to join is
worth the
efforts
furthermore we cannot forget that beyond
the question of accession in the
narrower sense progress is made along
the path to membership the Western
Balkans accession process began in
Berlin years ago
I remember that it was very tedious at
first
but when I think about the last Summit I
think that travel with personal identity
cards reciprocal recognition of school
and University diplomas and degrees the
willingness of European support despite
Rising Energy prices
those are significant steps forward
so I understand the impatience no
question but we are not in a phase that
calls for dejectedness certainly not
because of Ukraine as we continue to
keep our eye on the western Balkan
States and on North Macedonia and
Albania where there has been progress
the EU expects fast reforms from the
Western Balkans but also says that it
must perform itself before it can take
in new members and begin negotiations
how long do you think that process will
actually last
it should go as quickly as possible but
I'll admit that at this moment I do not
see signs suggesting the Swift reform of
European institutions
since I have known European institutions
from the inside for years I know that we
have had a series of multiple crises
we remember the Eurozone crisis
we remember more clearly the so-called
Refugee crisis in 2015 and 2016.
we had a huge challenge for the European
Union in fighting the coronavirus
pandemic
naturally these crises all followed one
another in Rapid succession and as we
can see now some like the pandemic and
the Russian invasion of Ukraine continue
to weigh upon us
that absorbs a lot of energy while at
the same time not leaving much mental
capacity for inner reforms which I will
concede are desperately needed
most of the western Balkan states have
shown great solidarity during the war in
Ukraine they have implemented sanctions
against Russia despite major concerns
about the consequences but Serbia has
repeatedly put its close ties to Moscow
on display is the EU doing enough to
support the Western Balkans in their
solidarity with Ukraine and how should
it deal with Serbia
um
to answer the first part of your
question that is one of the reasons I am
visiting the region because of course I
also want to get a feel for the mood in
those countries
and I think we will get a clear picture
of the mood whether North Macedonia and
Albania in this situation in which they
have not only showed solidarity with
Ukraine not only proven themselves by
helping increase economic pressure on
Russia but rather where countries like
North Macedonia and Albania also fulfill
their obligations within NATO and even
beyond that for Albania which currently
sits on the UN Security Council
I'd say that's quite a lot that we can
look at that we should respect
but it should also spark self-confidence
in those countries
I'm sure I will get a sense of whether
that is the case during my trip
to answer the second part of your
question regarding Serbia we have to
continue efforts to convince Serbia that
the path it is currently following is
Raising questions and concerns about how
serious the country is about finding its
way into Europe
um
I've been accompanying the Western
Balkans Journey towards the European
Union for nearly 20 years
and I've been to Serbia often
I'm certain that the people of Serbia
don't want to step away from the desire
shared with many other Western Balkan
states to grow closer to the European
Union and eventually become a member
therefore I can only hope and continue
to attempt to convince Serbia's
political leadership to pursue this path
more clearly
a word about this conflict between
Serbia and Kosovo but has been settled
at the last minute
what can Germany and Europe do to
contain this security risk in the region
in the long term that will have to
answer them and
investing conflicts
as for the conflict I find it A fitting
final question because its resolution
shows once again how important Europe
and the European Union are for the
region
if there were no desire to look to
Europe then Europe would not have
negotiating leverage in such conflicts
between Serbia and Kosovo
nevertheless I am still convinced that
it is the desire to come to Europe to
eventually join the European Union a
wish that is prominent in all of the
western Balkan states that gives Europe
leverage and the possibility to
negotiate and thus the ability to help
find a solution in this seemingly tiny
at least in our eyes seemingly
manageable conflict over automobile
license plates
if tiny conflicts can be dealt with then
perhaps larger conflicts could also be
peacefully resolved contributing to a
normalization of relations between
Serbia and Kosovo
president steinmeier thanks for speaking
to us thank you